I don't want to segue on her AI but
we've touched on it so I'm going to do
anyway the control problem for AI is
something that's difficult I think not
allowing our creations to go out of hand
is there a similar concern with regards
to developing these tools for longevity
that you could nefarious group could get
ahold of the technology and then
weaponize it or do something really
really sort of untoward well yeah always
you can turn technology against humanity
I'm not worried about that so much with
what I do because even though we have
the technology to make mice and probably
people aged rapidly
it'll be about the slowest way to damage
your enemies there are much more
efficient in the head as all has been
created as a pretty efficient way to
there's there's that and somewhere in
between you know we could pretty easily
unleash a deadly virus that wouldn't be
too far beyond what we could even do in
this lab not that we would but yeah but
in terms of making people age
prematurely we should consent me do it
and I could take you downstairs or maybe
somewhere I shouldn't say and there if
there are mice that we can control their
aging process forward and backwards so
that's doable um where I think people
get uncomfortable with this technology
is so we now understand that there are
genes that control how long we live
there's one for example called FOXO
which is turned on in wales and longer
lived animals than us
there are even human variants my
children were lucky enough to of them
out of three to inherit two really good
copies of this longevity gene and so
they're probably gonna live a lot longer
than my wife and I will um so we know a
lot about that so why does this get
weird well now that we can CRISPR
engineer babies what's gonna happen when
the world's most intent helicopter
parent wants a kid that can live 220
that's probably doable right now whether
or not we should is another question
whose job is it to work out whether or
not we should well right now there's a
worldwide debate among scientists about
whether we should come out
against it interestingly when when human
stem cells were first discovered and
that you could reprogram cells and clone
animals there was a much greater
backlash
you probably remember the the Blair Bush
days where there were all these in these
committees set up and it was banned here
in the US but we had something just as
big happen last year was that the
Chinese researcher professor he had a
couple of well-engineered a couple of
twins twin girls who were resistant
going to be resistant to HIV infection
and he and you know engineered those
genetically now there was a little bit
of upset a lot of scientists got upset
because this was announced without any
warning at a scientific conference there
was no oversight there was no
consultation with governments or other
scientists so the shock really took us
all by surprise but there was no major
backlash there hasn't been yet there
hasn't been any outlawing you certainly
don't hear a lot of backlash at the
higher levels of government over here in
the US at least um I think that's
healthy I think that what we've got is a
very rational debate and that we
shouldn't just overreact just because
something feels weird or isn't has never
been done before now we need to discuss
not just the ethics but is it safe and
that I think safety is more important
than than ethics actually and what I
mean by that is someone's ethics might
be different than yours I mean usually I
come down on the side of freedom to do
things as long as they're safe and that
they're beneficial and there's some
consent but in this case what's tricky
is that your children don't have consent
so that's why I think it's it's a hard
one but what if your child was
definitely going to get say a dominant
genetic disease and there was no way to
get around it except either have new
parents or don't breed or to have an
abortion what would be an example of a
dominant genetic disease so Huntington's
for example if both parents have
Huntington's you can or even one you can
have a
a child with Huntington's I mean you can
always select the embryo but maybe you
don't want to kill embryos so maybe you
could create an embryo that you go in
with this CRISPR editing system and chop
out the bad Huntington's gene and create
healthy child that should be doing
[Music]
you